[Musique]
regardez dj avec mike alors sa gelée
sortis normalement il est à l'intérieur
on va faire comme si on n'avait pas vu
pour l'instant on commence directement
la boîte est assez simple on a les
fonctionnalités principales elle s'ouvre
comme ça juste en dessous et l'a ensuite
on vient tirer et là normalement vous
avez ça à l'intérieur donc ça le
surélève mais j'ai déjà enlevés au
mexique
regardez il ya ce à l'intérieur ça c'est
vachement intéressant parce que en fait
c'est une espèce de power banque dans
laquelle vous allez tous retrouvés à
l'intérieur ça permet d'avoir une très
grosse autonomie les transmetteurs on
5h50 d'autonomie le récepteur 5 heures
et avec l'étui vous monte à 15 heures
d'autonomie donc ça c'est un truc qui
est vachement bien et moi j'ai utilisé
différents micros mais ça je l'avais pas
j'avais passé deux possibilités la
faille que je leur charge ce qui fait
que lorsque vous avez fini et que vous
les reposer dedans eh bien ils vont se
charger il se trouve que c'est vraiment
vraiment bien et en plus comme vous avez
un petit écran la tout écrit vous voyez
exactement les batteries ou est-ce que
vous en êtes ce qui fait qu'il ya pas de
mauvaise surprise avant de commencer un
tournage et la même manière vous avez
ici une petite led regardez up lorsque
vous l'ouvrez vous voyez le niveau de
batterie restants on va appeler ça une
espèce de grande power banque année tu
c'est plutôt un étui puisqu'une power
banques à l'intérieur on retrouve le
premier transmetteur le deuxième
transmetteur le récepteur et deux trucs
qui sont vachement vachement vachement
bien c'est ces trucs là gardez vous avez
un ici et un ici et en fait ça ça permet
quoi ça permet de transformer votre
récepteur en petit récepteur on peut
connecter très facilement pour injecter
le son directement notamment dans un
smartphone dans tout ce que vous voulez
vous n'avez plus qu'à le prendre une
petite flèche qui vous indique le sens
vous prenez ça hop vous le prenez vous
le tournez vous l'avancé j'ai plus qu'à
prendre mon iphone et ça je viens et je
le plug directement dans lightning is it
qui fait que tout le son qui va être
enregistrées va venir directement ici
vous avez également cette petite partie
là qui est intéressant qui vous servira
à venir poser votre récepteur sur un
boîtier ou le prenais regarder up de la
même manière vous venez vous prenez vous
soulevez cette partie là et vous venez
le glisser directement à l'intérieur
comme ça voilà jusqu'au bout et ensuite
ça vous venez vous levez évoulent
insérer directement dans votre boîtier
très facilement
et comme on peut venir le mettre
directement sur smartphones l'année si
ça marche donc la leçon et enregistrait
directement sur mon iphone qui est posée
là on va laisser
l'iphone positionner juste quatre ans le
boîtier on va se battre on y va on va
loin comme ça au moins hop voilà comme
ça vous voyez vous savez tout donc là
c'est pareil on est loin donc là
normalement faire on continue avec on
ressort hop on viens par ici la même
chose et on repart en bas et normalement
on a bien tout le son qui est
enregistrée ici uniquement avec l'iphone
ensuite vous ressortez en poussant ici
c'est un peu dur mais ça finit par
sortir vous avez la même chose ici avec
de l'usb seydoux n'importe quel
smartphone android offre à la faire et
puis ensuite à l'intérieur vous allez
retrouver ici regardez hop ça souffle
comme ça un petit étui pour venir ranger
il balader partout avec vous ou très
facilement mais c'est pas tout une bonne
est anti vent lorsque vous allez venir
un shooter à l'extérieur que vous prenez
et que vous venez poser dessus sans
votre micro l'art optique vous tournez à
les poser facilement en plus de vins
très joli style axé petit peu mouthe
alors il y en a une deuxième bien
évidemment parce qu'il y en a deux vous
avez une prise jack parce que oui
effectivement pouvait venir branché ici
votre récepteur directement sur un
boîtier par exemple comme moi
directement l'assurance et s3 alors tout
de suite je ne tombe pas avec lui parce
que je vous le monde peut pas tout faire
en même temps vous avez également un
câble en usb c'est usb pour venir
recharger votre étui facilement et si
vous avez entre eux mais clés tu pouvais
venir également les recharger eux
directement en usb c'est vous avez des
prises disponibles directement sur les
produits et si on en retrouvait des
documentations dite de sécurité enfin
bref c'est très simple gardez là par
exemple je les poser directement sur mon
boitier donc ça c'est plutôt pratique je
me suis mis un petit gain l'enjeu voilà
le mkc je me suis mis un gain moins
quatre ans fait peuple a bien dû
récepteur voyez je l'aimé c'est pour
être sûr que ça fonctionnerait bien
parce que moi je parle un peu fort
regardez si vous regardez 1-2 your pop
up parce que vraiment je suis très très
fort et après une fois que celui-là
voyez si je passe pas en bas soit que
sont le transmetteur 2 je vois le temps
d'enregistrement qui me reste et je peux
venir le mettre en mode si je souhaite
garder la petite barreau qui me dit coop
je peux descendre comme ça directement
sur mon mieux donc l'algérie face à moi
parce que comme si en train de filmer
j'ai les infos et c'est à ces pratiques
sans votre récepteur vous avez un écran
qui en fait un écran tactile donc ça
c'est vachement cool gardez vous venez
la vie et hop vous descendez comme ça
vous avez vos menus mono vous pouvez
choisir de passer en mono ou carrément
en stéréo si vous le souhaitez ensuite
hop vous repasser vers le bas vous avez
votre gain d'entre elles pourraient bien
choisir entre -12 et +12 alors attention
restez l'heure zéro db ensuite le volume
de sortie au niveau de votre casque
parce que oui vous avez une prise jack
pour venir monitorer ce que vous
enregistrez ça c'est vachement bien
aussi les différents paramètres
notification de vibrations apparaît
l'appareil le gain du transmetteur
pareil vous choisissez les gains directs
- devaux transmetteur ici la luminosité
la langue la date et l'heure on peut
ensuite passer en par ahmed usine la
version les infos de conformité impasse
bas si vous souhaitez mettre un pass bas
qui va venir vous couper un peu tout et
des choses qui vont venir ronronnait je
pense en dessous de 150 hertz donc là il
émit par défaut comme on est sur un
micro pour de l'avant peut mettre le
pass bas-rhin très honnêtement et
ensuite vous revenez comme ça ici la
voyez sur le haut et vous arrivez sur
votre écran d'accueil là vous avez sur
le côté donc la sortie jack pour venir
écouter pour bien monitorer la sortie
pour venir grancher notamment dans un
boîtier directement si on le réussit
avec l'aprilia qui fournit avec les
connectiques fournir branché du lighting
de l'usbc est là pour venir le
rechercher vous êtes petit bouton
convenir l'allumé pour l'éteindre c'est
extrêmement simple et pareil sur les
récepteurs vous allez avoir le bouton
pour l'allumer pour l'éteindre vous
allez avoir ici de l'usbc pour venir
directement leurs charges et si besoin
votre micro une petite prise jack si
vous souhaitez brancher un micro en
entrée un lave alliés notamment pour
venir mais ça dans votre poche pourquoi
pas et ensuite bas regardez vous avez
une petite pince pour d'un clip c'est si
vous aimez pas le côté pince regardez
vous pouvez prendre ça vous avez un
aimant qui est très honnêtement très
très puissante qui vous permet ensuite
de venir imposer voyez par exemple sur
le vêtement comme ça avec les mots comme
ça vous le mettez vous voulez ça dépend
des vêtements vous allez c'est très
puissant donc ça bouge pas ou alors
sinon vous venez pincez moi
personnellement le penser ça me va bien
alors après il un peu lourd donc sur un
tee shirt ça peut tomber ou pourquoi pas
à ce moment là bien m
or ya un truc est vraiment intéressant
ici c'est que comme je vais avoir deux
transmetteurs je peux bien enregistré
différemment sur chaque canal la journée
active et qu'un seul ce qui fait qu'en
fait regarder si vous voyez ça envoie le
signal des deux côtés donc en stéréo
j'ai ma voix ici lorsque je suis en
train de parler donc là c'est plutôt
bien mais lorsque je vais avoir un
interlocuteur avec moi et bien ça va
venir splitter ça va envoyer d'un côté
sur la gauche ma voix par exemple et sur
la droite ça va envoyer la voix de mon
interlocuteur ce qui permettra de
pouvoir venir traiter les deux pistes
complètement différemment si moi par
exemple j'ai besoin d'avoir un
traitement particulier et mon
interlocuteur d'avoir un autre
traitement voit bien c'est possible donc
ça c'est vachement bien de la même
manière pour mettre des biens dans très
différents pour toutes la question de
post production derrière et si quelqu'un
par exemple à une sifflante sur la voie
je peux venir la récupérer la corriger
directement aller quoi l'isr tout en
sachant et ça c'est vachement bien c'est
à dire qu' il va faire un enregistrement
à l'intérieur directement et pas
uniquement en sortie dans votre boîtier
le truc est super avec ça c'est que ça
vous fait une sauvegarde à - 6 db si par
exemple comme moi vous gueulez un peu
tout le temps permanence avec une voix
qui pousse et bien ça vous permettra de
récupérer un enregistrement cidb en
dessous et ça vous permettra d'avoir une
sauvegarde et ce truc là c'est super mal
mais vraiment et s'il ya un truc est
cool c'est que vous avez jusqu'à 250 m
de portée sur la bande de fréquence de
2,4 giguère ce qui fait qu'on peut aller
se balader on peut aller faire le tour à
dire je vous faire faire le tour enfin
retour de la part du propriétaire comme
ça vous verrez j'enregistre ici pour que
vous voyez un peu ce qui se passe
directement avec mon iphone les leçons
et enregistrer directement ici donc ça
c'est pas du tout le son de l'iphone
qu'on va conserver alors regardez là il
est posé donc là déjà je commençais par
m'éloigner on va même grimpé à laitages
comme ça au moins je pars hop ça vous
voyez mes chaussettes vous voyez avec
complète donc là ça met en lumière sinon
on n'y voit rien du tout on vient par la
voyez des gens et faire un tour dans la
salle de bain donc là je suis vraiment
dans une autre pièce je suis monté à
l'étagé une fois de plus on n'est pas le
son de l'iphone en mai vraiment
uniquement le son du du micro regardez
il est là d'ailleurs ils y sont si je
fais ça ça marchera pas
vous le voyez alors on continue hop on
sort on va de l'autre côté et on revient
ici donc ici de la même manière
l'enregistreur est en bas et on ne peut
pas le cas précis je coupe la garder
et hop ensuite on redescend par sommes
directement ici et on revient là voilà
il ya dans tout cas c'est intéressant ça
que lorsque vous êtes en extérieur vous
allez vous loguez fait les choses comme
ça pourrait vous inquiétez lorsqu'il ya
beaucoup de monde dans des lieux dans
des centres commerciaux dans des gares &
company et et bien ils ont mis un
système de capacités anti interférences
qui va venir empêcher les interférences
pour que vous gardez uniquement votre
signaler que vous récupériez pas d
signale parasites qui pourrait venir à
l'extérieur et au niveau de la capacité
d'enregistrement vous êtes tranquilles
jusqu'à 14h directement en interne alors
si comme moi tout de suite vous
enregistrer dans un boîtier ya pas de
souci ça va dépendre de la capacité
d'enregistrement de votre boîtier ou de
votre smartphone mais en interne vous
avez ce qu'il faut et ça aussi c'est
bien
je pense que vous le voyez mais c'est
vraiment un produit que j'aime bien
parce que ça permet vraiment de venir
enregistrer partout on veut de la
meilleure des manières ça fait à peine
30 g donc c'est extrêmement léger c'est
facile il ya plusieurs fonctionne et et
qui sont extrêmement importantes le
premier c'est d'ailleurs cet étui qui
sert de power banque qui vous permet de
le recharger vous savez tout le temps où
vous en êtes moi j'utilise beaucoup de
produits qui viennent de la concurrence
j'ai souvent gagné dans le genre à
munger plus beaucoup de batteries faut
que je recharge fait pas réellement où
j'en étais là je suis vraiment
tranquille je peux juste à 15 heures
d'enregistrement en autonomie de grâce
est cool et le deuxième point qui est
vraiment extrêmement important pour moi
c'est le fait que je puisse l'utiliser
sur un iphone comme tout de suite de
façon très simple avant ce que je
faisais c'est que je prenais je faisais
ici mon récepteur je venais le brancher
en lightning avec un câblage et même pas
besoin il vient se poser directement
dessus donc ça c'est quand même regarder
vachement pratique je peux le mettre
dans un sens ou dans l'autre là je le
mets dans ce sens là ça me permet
d'avoir le vu m face à moi comme ça
voyez mais si je vais utiliser la caméra
de cellfish peut également le mettre
face à moi donc ça c'est vachement
intéressant c'est vachement malin et je
trouve ça juste génial parce qu'en fait
ils ont fait un truc j'ai dit 'je sais
qu'ils ont réfléchi aux usages ils ont
réfléchi à ce dont les gens avaient
besoin ils ont réfléchi vraiment tout
simple garder je peux l'emmener je
galère pas c'est très simple c'est malin
et ça c'est très cool et ça me plaît et
c'est vraiment je trouve hyper
intéressant avec ce produit alors je
vais relégué le produit que j'ai utilisé
de la concurrence je vais le mettre
d'ailleurs je ne sais plus utilisé chez
vraiment à quelque chose avec ça parce
que j'aime bien en plus sa qualité audio
est là et c'est drôle parce que dj hi
c'est une marque qui était connu par les
drones on a vu que le marché du drone
exploser un moment et après c'est quand
même bien redescendu la hype est quand
même reparti bien plus en bas la
réglementation il a joué énormément et
il cherche plein de produits différents
pour venir se positionner et ils
réussissent vachement bien parce qu'ils
sont des produits qui sont de super
bonne qualité est là avec le dj mike
déjà unique le dj mythe le dj mike dj
mike c'est génial parce que ça répond à
une problématique très précise des
créateurs et comme de plus en plus de
créateurs sur smartphone pour me
retourner tout de suite mais également
sur un boîtier et bien je trouve que le
boulot est fait jobs is done revient à
l'américaine le boulot est fait et je
trouve ça vraiment bien alors je sais
pas si vous êtes créateur ici est en
recherche de solutions et de produits
comme ça mais si c'est le cas et bien
très honnêtement je vous invite plus
plus plus à venir essayer ce dj mike
alors c'est pas parce que c'est
aujourd'hui une vidéo qui réalise un
partenariat avec dj mais parce que - ton
créateur souffler la solution est
vraiment extrêmement bonne et je peux
que vous la recommande est donc allé
jeter un oeil aux emmy lien en bas dans
la description et un dernier élément
dont on n'a pas parlé qui est
extrêmement important c'est le prix 329
euros alors oui c'est un budget mais
vous avez un récepteur vous avez deux
transmetteurs vous avez un boîtier qui
sert de recharge vous avez plein
d'outils vous avez plein d'adaptateurs
de tous les côtés c'est extrêmement
modulaire et c'est ça que j'ai vraiment
trouvé très intéressant alors on n'est
pas sur une solution de broadcast
professionnels soyons clairs on est sur
une solution qui va plus servir pour des
créateurs que ce soit comme moi sur
youtube des tic toc hurd et instagram
heures et tout ce qui finit en heure
mais des broadcaster donc ça finit en
euros si enfin des gens qui sont
professionnels de l'audiovisuel ce n'est
pas nécessairement fait pourquoi que à
réfléchir voilà c'est ce que je voulais
raconter je trouve ça super intéressant
bravo dj hi super boulot personnellement
je pense que j'ai fait une très belle
découverte et je continue à m'amuser
avec et ça c'est chouette je vous
embrasse pour les soins de vous il ya
bientôt 15
[Musique]